hey if you haven't already got it get
yourself a copy of answer the Internet
the card game it's available right now
in the link in the bio or you can get a
bar salal Mart Amazon or Spencer Gifts
play along with us let's get into it
hey I'm Doug Smith and this is answer
the internet let's see if you had to
choose one cartoon animal to have sex
with who would it be
man I got to narrow it down to one huh
I think it would probably be well I was
gonna say Nala from The Lion King but
she's underage so that's probably not a
good choice of age oh she's of age now
she's older than me now yeah Nala get
some of that cougar action if you could
die and come back as any inanimate
object what would it be I would come
back as a probably is a weapon of some
sort is that I probably come back as
like a samurai sword because I would
want to be used in action my brother
actually keeps a samurai sword under his
bed for intruders I always thought that
was kind of a strange thing so I would
love to I would love to be the head
samurai sword how long would it take you
to eat your own bodyweight in hot dogs
150 hot dogs at 1.5 so so this is just a
math question
I don't know it'd probably take me at
least a week I guess a week way more
than a week need 150 pounds of hot dogs
I think it would take me a week cuz I
don't really like hot dogs
nearly 1800 hotdogs in a week bring it
on Kobayashi
who's the hottest celebrity you'd have a
chance with if they got to know you when
I was walking dogs in I was walking in
the West Village I used to see
celebrities all the time and Olivia
Wilde once smiled at me completely
unprovoked so I just booted that dog
across the straighter line let's do it
right here right now all right would you
rather throw up anytime someone says
McDonald's or wear a fedora for the rest
of your life and if anybody asks you
about it you have to say I like the way
it looks I would choose because believe
it or not I was a a genuine fedora wear
for a brief time if you could make your
girlfriend's breasts as large as you
wanted but yours would be the same size
how big would you go I'd have no problem
with a pair of double D's I'd be walking
like that guy you mention it how long
would you have to starve to become a
cannibal
I'd eat either one of you guys by the
end of the day no problem I've always
been curious about the taste of human
flesh - there's got to be a restaurant
somewhere this on the DL right is sex
with conjoined twins a threesome yeah
there yeah I say if there's two separate
brains it's to set it's a threesome who
would win in a battle royale 30 midgets
verse one full-grown lion I love
questions like this 30 minutes
first one full-grown lion 30 midgets
will definitely win yeah 30 that's
that's a lot that's a lot of manpower
and they're small they're stocky they're
low to the ground they would grab the
lion around his legs pin him down
a couple of them would just take his
jaws or just rip his [ __ ] head in
half I think this is the kind of thing I
think about a lot I think I could kill a
police dog with my bare hands no problem
yeah absolutely you're nuts you would
get [ __ ] up in the process but you
have more you have more to work with all
they have is their jaws yeah I mean you
can grab him punch him this is what I
used to think about while I was walking
German Shepherds - if your owner doesn't
tip me this Christmas I think I think if
the thing is charging at you you duck
out of the way you flip them over you
and then yeah ideally you want to snap
his neck first but if you can't do that
just yeah just get him in a headlock and
then you can do whatever you want yeah I
mean like I said you'd you'd be [ __ ]
up but if it was to the death I think he
could win how much money would it take
you to verbally belittle a [ __ ] in
front of a crowd of a hundred people you
mean how much money would I pay to be
able to do that
the little a [ __ ] bear for 100 people
five bucks no no press is bad press how
many grown men would it take to kill a
grizzly bear with their bare hands if
his sensei was the police dog [ __ ] his
ass up groan mmm I'd say probably I'd
say probably at least 12 full-grown men
to take down a grizzly bear because that
is just tremendous weight I mean and
that's not just teeth that's serious
claws I mean anyone who'd seen the
revenant I think
can back me up on that yeah it's it's a
it doesn't you think more yeah well well
how big are these are these like dudes
like us for the is it 12 the rocks
regular ask guys I don't know I think I
think you gotta believe in yourself more
man alright would you have sex with a
dead person yes for five minutes if
you'd get your laundry done and folded
magically for the rest of your life
absolutely I'd have sex with my Chinese
laundry lady if I could get that done
[Laughter]
man should have belittled that [ __ ]
when I had the chance
yeah absolutely I hate I hate doing
laundry so yes I would I would bring
that dead person to orgasm if I would
get hey man you got a stick out in this
business any way you can